Is the way you're writing about your
expertise stopping readers from seeing
its value? For many experts, the answer
is yes. They write about their ideas and
experience in a way that makes sense to
them, but the patterns that you use to
write are different than the patterns
that readers use to understand. So, in
this video, I'm going to show you two
nonfiction writing patterns that will
make your ideas leap off the page and
into the mind of your readers. I've been
teaching academic and professional
writing for 10 years, and this is one of
the lessons that I've developed to help
writers see that the words that you
choose are less important than the
patterns that you use to organize them.
And to help you see how this works,
first I'm going to show you the original
text that we're going to be editing
today. Then I'm going to show you some
patterns and principles that we're going
to try to implement, and finally, we
will use those patterns and principles
to fix this plate of spaghetti into
something that's more coherent and
organized. So, as I read this passage,
try to see if you can tell what's gone
wrong with it. So, it says, "Many issues
other than science, domestic politics in
particular, faced Truman when he was
considering the Oppenheimer committee's
recommendation to stop the hydrogen bomb
project. A Sino-Soviet bloc had been
proclaimed by Russia and China, so the
Cold War was becoming an issue. Support
for Truman's foreign policy was
shrinking among Republican leaders in
Congress. And the first Russian atom
bomb test made the public demand a
strong response from him.
Truman's conclusion that he could not
afford letting the public think that
Russian
that Russia had been allowed to be the
first in developing the most powerful
weapon yet was an inevitable one. The
risk in the Oppenheimer recommendation
was worth taking, according to some
historians, but the political issues
that Truman had to face were too
powerful to ignore. So, obviously, that
passage is a mess, but what's wrong with
it? Well, there are really two things at
work here, and it doesn't have to do
with vocabulary or grammar. It has to do
with the principles that are organizing
the information. And so, basically,
whenever you look at any given sentence,
there are some fixed elements and some
variable elements. So, the fixed
elements at the level of syntax are
something you probably know well from
grammar class, subject, verb, object,
and then on the other side of them, we
have these two adverbs, prepositional
phrases, um transitional phrases, that
kind of thing. And those aren't moving.
You're never going to have the subject
over here or the verb over there. These
are fixed. Similarly, one level that
many writers don't realize is that at
the level of organization, you also have
these two elements, which is the topic,
and that extends from the beginning of
the sentence, including the adverb, up
until the end of the subject, and then
anything after the subject, like
including the verb and then anything
that comes after that, we call the
comment. I'll explain that a little bit
more in depth in a moment, but these are
the two fixed structures that we're
going to be looking at as we try to
diagnose what's gone wrong with this
passage and how we can fix it. And the
basic principle that we're going to be
trying to implement is that we are going
to be taking characters and actions.
Right? So, the these are variable. Like,
every sentence is going to have
characters and there are going to be
actions. And so, let's say, for example,
you were just trying to make this simple
sentence. You could say, "Bees make
honey." And that would be fine, but
these are variable, so you can move
these things around. You can say, "Honey
is made by bees." Right, we have to
change the tense here, so that would
become is made
by bees. Bees would be over here in the
adverb.
"By bees." Or you could even say,
"The making of honey." And that's a
character, but the making of honey
is carried out
by bees. So, the point here is that at
the level of characters and actions, you
have options. They're variable. And the
principle that we're trying to be
implementing in this passage is putting
characters in the subject position and
actions in the verb. But at a second
level, at the level of organization, you
also have new information and old
information. Old information might come
from something the readers already know,
right? Background information that you
assume they're familiar with. Other
times that background information is
going to be provided in the passage. So,
terms that you've already introduced
before. And so, the basic principle here
at the level of organization is that we
are going to put consistent, familiar
context at the beginning of the sentence
and new, emphasis-worthy information
over here at the end of the sentence, in
the comment.
And when you think about these two
principles, I think this is really
what's gone wrong with this passage. So,
as I've mapped it out for you here,
we see all all these line all these
reference lines, that's a sign that
something has gone wrong here. So, we're
going to be using these two principles
to try to rewrite this passage in a way
that is well organized and easy to
follow. And so, to do that, we'll just
start with sentence one. I'll copy this.
And what I've done here is I've
highlighted the characters in green and
the actions in red. And any of these
grammar words, prepositions and that
kind of thing, I just highlighted in
gray because they don't really have any
semantic content. So, this passage says,
"Many issues other than science,
domestic politics in particular,
faced Truman
when he" That's linking back over to
Truman, was considering the Oppenheimer
committee's recommendation to stop the
hydrogen bomb project. And so, I know
that this passage as a whole is about
the different issues that he faced,
especially domestic politics. So,
because that's new information, I know
that I want to put that at the end of
the passage. Right? That's going to be
controlling um the the rest of the
passage. It it like it it sets the kind
of context for everything that follows.
And I know that Truman is a recurring
character. So, I want to put him at the
beginning of the passage in the subject.
Now, because we're going to be ending
with many issues
um he faced, he faced many issues.
So, we could say when Truman
was considering the Oppenheimer
committee's recommendation
to stop the hydrogen bomb process,
he
faced many issues. I guess that would be
was faced.
Was faced
with many issues other than
He was faced or would that be by? He was
faced by
many issues other than science, domestic
politics in particular. And that's
great, because now we have introduced
this um important information at the end
of the passage in the comment position.
And that receives emphasis and it's
going to control our interpretation of
the rest of the passage. It's a position
that I sometimes call the index
position, because all the other elements
ideally, those here in the topic
position, are going to index that
information. They're going to link back
up to it. So, in the next sentence, we
have this one about a Soviet block by
Russia and China. So, I'll copy this
down here.
Now, one little thing that kind of
bugged me about this passage is
um notice it's a Sino-Soviet block. So,
Sino-Soviet that would be China and
Russia. But, over here we have Russia
and China. So, I mean that might be a
little ADD, but I think China and Russia
makes things parallel. But, now these
are the characters, right? China and
Russia are the characters.
And this is like a thing that they have
declared. So, I think it works better
if we reverse these.
Russia and China
um had
proclaimed
a Sino-Soviet block.
That works out well.
Okay. Then, the next passage, and the
Cold War was becoming an issue.
Uh for whom? Among
Was it just becoming an issue? Oh, it
was so so the Cold War was becoming an
issue.
Okay. Oh, yeah, and I know what we can
do here. So, let's copy this, bring it
down here.
So, the Cold War
was becoming an issue. You know what?
Instead of See, so that's what we call a
um what is that called? A It's linking
two independent clauses. Fanboys is a
coordinating conjunction. And what this
word so is doing is it's giving these
two clauses equal emphasis. But, anytime
there are two clauses and one of them is
providing an interpretation of the other
one, I always think it works better.
Like, they're not equally important. One
of them is the event and the other one
is an interpretation of that event. So,
let's not put it into an independent
clause. Let's use what's called a
non-restrictive
relative clause, which just means a
comma plus the word which. Right? So,
China and Russia had proclaimed a
Sino-Soviet bloc,
um
which
made the Cold War an issue.
So, that would be
was becoming. How about
made?
And then
which goes here.
Which made
the Cold War an issue. But, cool thing
about um these non-restrictive relative
clauses is anytime you're using one to
provide uh these very common uses of it,
a definition, or to write about the
effect of something, or to um provide an
interpretation of it, you can reduce it.
You can delete the the non-restrictive
pronoun and you can turn this into a
non-finite ing. Making the Cold War an
issue. That works pretty well.
All right. And now we can go back up and
what comes after that?
Let's see.
Cold War was becoming an issue and it
also like
it gets rid of this intransitive verb.
You know, I hate these intransitive
verbs. Like very um few things in the
world are actually intransitive. You
know, like uh the sun ri- like nature is
intransitive. So, the sun rises, leaves
fall, wind blows, but the Cold War
didn't become an issue.
An action made it an issue. So, it's
better to use a transitive verb here.
Um making the Cold War an issue. And
then we go on to another domestic pol-
another domestic issue.
Um which is support
for uh his policy was shrinking among
Republican leaders in Congress. Okay,
and this is a second issue.
So, we should have some kind of
transitional device here like
even if it's just the word and.
Or we could even just do like first, you
know, first, second, finally. So, first
and first works well there because now
we can just it kind of links up
to this thing that we introduced in the
index position. And this is a great I
don't love this kind of um
all these signposts all over the place,
but whenever you're dealing with all of
this kind of complex heavy information,
it's great to link these things back up
to that index position.
Cuz it helps the reader stay focused.
You know, it helps them see
uh the connections that you're painting
here. So, second, support for Truman's
foreign policy,
well, that is not a character. So,
definitely we want to bring
uh
Republican
leaders. We might have to change the
verb here. Republican leaders in
Congress, yeah, we have to like we can't
just use the same action here. So,
shrinking, but now that we have them in
the subject position, we have to think
we we want to use something like losing,
right? They were were losing
faith. How about losing faith? It's
support, right? No, we don't want to say
they no longer supported. Um so, we but
we could say they were
losing
faith
in Truman's foreign policy.
That'd be way to fix it.
Of course, there are different ways. You
can drop it in the comments if you have
other suggestions here.
But, I'm going to go with losing faith
in Truman's foreign policy. And of
course, Truman is going to link back up
to our man Truman.
That up there.
But, you know what? Now that I think
about it, this is new and this is new
information, isn't it? And Truman is old
information. So, let's try this,
actually. Let's bring Truman's foreign
policy back in here. Yeah, and actually
and foreign policy links nicely to
Russia and China. So, we could say
Truman's foreign policy
was losing support
from
Republican leaders in Congress.
That works out well, because this again
allows us to put the new information,
the new emphasis-worthy
here at the end of the sentence.
I'm zooming back up.
So, those are two domestic issues.
And the first Russian atom bomb test
made the public demand a strong response
from him. Because there are so many
characters and so many actions in this
sentence, I think we're going to break
it up into two clauses, into a cause and
effect.
Third,
the Russians
tested
the atom bomb
and the public, that caused the public
to demand
a strong response from him.
Well, because we're dealing with
domestic
issues, we don't want to emphasize this
one. So, let's kind of minimize it.
with
Third,
since
the Russians
had been
first
to test the atom bomb,
right? So, since the Russians had been
first to test the atom bomb, the public
demanded
a strong response from him.
Well, we don't want him at the end here.
So, why don't we say demanded
that he respond
strongly
or his strong response.
Right? And again, this lets us
link up
to him.
And this
is
one of the issues that he's dealing
with.
I guess it would be the third one here.
Right? So, these are three domestic
issues that he's dealing with.
And now this is the sentence that really
went off the rails, but there's a quick
fix for it.
Look at how overloaded this subject is.
That tells you right away that something
has gone wrong.
So, we'll bring that down here. We'll
open this up.
And this is a kind of some. These are
the, you know, these are the three
domestic issues that he's dealing with,
and now we're going to be kind of
linking back up
to this consideration.
So, he was considering these things and
therefore he concluded. So, we need to
we need to because there's just this
empty verb now. So, it's kind of like
you know, these three points we kind of
package them all together. And now after
considering those three points, we now
come to a conclusion. I think conclude.
So, I think I think conclude is going to
go here in the verb.
So,
Truman concluded
and the idea here is inevitable one.
Truman, you could say inevitably
concluded
if you wanted.
And then he concluded that he could not
afford letting the public think that he
had been allowed to be the first in
developing the most powerful weapon yet.
And so because this subject is so
overloaded
with these details, we want to move them
to the end of the sentence into the
comment decision. So, let's take
inevitable out of there. We can just
treat that as an adverb. Truman
inevitably
concluded.
Just flag that as There we go. So,
Truman inevitably concluded
that What did he conclude? He concluded
that
he could not afford
letting
the public
think
that Russia had been allowed
to be first
in developing the most powerful weapon
yet.
That is the atom bomb. And the reason
this works is because it now moves all
this heavy information from the start of
the sentence in the topic position
to the end of the sentence where readers
can manage it more easily.
Sentence is really kind of like a runway
in a for a plane. You need to start with
simplicity and kind of familiar
background information and let readers
take off into the new complexity.
Okay, last sentence is
um about uh the risk in the Oppenheimer
recommendation was worth taking
according to some historians, but the
political issues
that Truman had to face were too
powerful to ignore.
Move those down here.
Well, I think ultimately we want to get
these historians out of that prominent
position and put it over here into an
adverbial phrase. So, some historians
According to some historians and then
risk is not a character.
So, we could say What could we say? It
was worth it?
Or how that should have Like he should
have risked
worth taking. Instead of worth taking,
we could just say
that
According to some historians, Truman
should have risked
Should have risked what?
Should have risked following
the Oppenheimer recommendation.
All right. But, the political issues
that Truman had to face
Well, we could just say Truman couldn't
ignore.
And that actually sums things up really
really nicely. Truman
could not ignore
these powerful
political issues.
And that works so nicely because it
links back up to sentence one.
So, let's make sure I have
all the chains of reference here.
See what happens when you when you
organize from old to new like this, when
you put backward linking context
in the at the start of the sentence in
the topic position,
you get these really nice patterns of
reference.
Truman, Truman, Truman.
So, just take a look at these patterns
of um coherence.
All right, these what I call topic
strings. If you just take a look at the
pattern that's emerging here, it works
it's so much more clean and organized.
Let's I just compare them here.
than this. Isn't that a lot neater? And
the the really when you zoom out like
this, the really important macro pattern
is that we're seeing the elements at the
beginning of the sentence. First of all,
the the subject is shorter, right? So,
it's not overloaded with details. These
lopsided uh front-loaded
sentences like this become a lot neater,
but also not only are they short and
compact in the topic position, but also
all the topics are linking back either
to Truman or to the political the
domestic political issues. And that's
really important because when your
readers are moving through your
sentence, they're expecting at the start
of the sentence to find backward linking
context and to have only new information
and kind of complex and heavy
information saved for the end of the
sentence. And the way that we did that
is this with two principles. So,
concrete characters in the subject,
important actions in the verb, and
consistent familiar topics at the start,
new complex information at the end in
the comment position. And if you want to
understand why this works so well, then
you need to watch this video next
because it's going to give you nine
reader-focused writing techniques that
are all based in reader psychology and
that'll give you a much stronger basis
for writing your next nonfiction piece.
So, be sure to go check it out.